good morning everyone this is day 2 with
Matt DJ mini Matt as we're calling him I
couldn't believe it was actually
available on Instagram and Twitter so DJ
mini Matt did a good job last night
sleeping how did you do a good job
sleeping last night sort of he only woke
me up two times two times he's having
his breakfast mm-hmm you don't know
DJ mini matt has to go to the vet today
for the first time I'm sure things that
I want to teach him but I want him to be
able to do sort of like locational kind
of stuff I want to teach him cage bag
rug and potty somebody likes the mana
rover okay nice try so solid effort
first times a little tricky
okay bud time to go to the V word do you
want to draw I'll Drive
ladies first I bet days is day to day -
you're with pig 63 stay - we don't yes
turn right shoot is it bakery is it up
two nights with them
hi sweetie it's okay - gotta get a
thermometer in the bud I don't know
yes we're gonna find out the mama and
blood cuz little piggies got worms
yeah that's pretty common for little
puppies though but he's on his little
medicine me only on the mat and Pete
thought himself until he left
Wow was very proud of it boy
1.3 he's definitely about happened he's
okay
Oh No whoo oh shoot don't know ones that
I Bendel's is there anything that can
clean it up with Oh God
it's okay they all he stepped in it all
right we're gonna go get him little
things to chew on some toys he's really
hungry we had to change up his little
diet because he's got diarrhea and
tapeworms poor friend but he's gonna be
all fixed up and healthy and and the vet
said she that he's gonna be really smart
he's such a proud mom good boy what and
I went and got you some treats I'm not
gonna spoil him too much not like brick
toilet bo bo has more clothes than
Brianne has this is where after bath
time is a bath towel his little treats
remember I said he gets one outfit but I
got him actually two outfits sir re line
yep look they're cute they're gonna fit
I know this is the extra small this is
an extra small also it smells so good
that's gonna be like excuse me I'm DJing
here oh boy we're yet you're probably
gonna have to poop Sam huh all right
ventures with Maddie Maddie and Justine
and Jenna continue boy adventures with
Matt and Matt and just the engine okay
bye
so we're gonna do Maddie's little first
training session right here right here
okay Oh
hmm it's going well okay
we're already city topologies oh gosh oh
this is a cool look here eat the food Oh
got the clicker yes believe he's a
smallmouth he's supposed to sit and on
the third session I say sit but he's not
Thank You professional
hmm good boy good boy good boy he's
doing good well then am i doing it right
I don't know usually you say sit you say
that the third time in third
he's so rolling his low like I fed him
before meal it was one treat Jomo head
spinnin good boy good boy good boy
squeeze again so Jenna was babysitting
little Matlock took a nap it's such a
headache I'd like a migraine it was
awful haven't slept in a few days cuz
somebody's been keeping me up but you're
worth that you know bud you just pooped
on the mat you still have tapeworms
though it makes me so sad for you so my
mom got us this grass thing and I
thought it was like a fake grass it's
real yeah you didn't tell me was real
it's real grass yeah real fresh what
George put it out like this it's really
yes yeah you leave it out there put in
the house the problems I don't want him
to go in the grass that is out there
because I think you might have like
fertilizer and they just sprayed for
ants so I'm scared I don't want him to
touch the grass and I'm too tired how's
my hair look
oh it's like sticking outside he likes
to just have person contact you to touch
him he's yours no face whoa whoa he's
still weird guys I'm in such disarray
right now
poor little Maddy is not feeling well he
has worms and his little tummies bloated
and then I searched the internet for
puppy stomach bloating and they said
that he's gonna die I'm like ah I'm not
cut out I'm not cut out for a little guy
he's still cold from his bath I would
have to take a shower and I put him in
his crate and he started crying and I
came down and pooped himself so I gave
him a bath I'm not gonna sleep tonight
at all anyway I'm gonna I don't know sit
and watch him all night I'll see you
later
thanks for all your puppy tips they're
extremely helpful and comforting
I'm gonna go dress out I know a puppy
mommy this is Matt